as you know the Western world
predominantly uses Arabic numerals for
mathematics but it never used to for
millennia Roman numerals were used but
why were they replaced what led to
Europe and the Western world adopting
Arabic numerals throughout the life of
the Roman Empire and the millennium
after its collapse in the West Roman
numerals were the only game in town
sidenote in case you're wondering much
of Eastern Europe used the Cyrillic
numeral system of the Bulgarian Empire
until Peter the Great's reforms in the
18th century
anyway whilst Roman numerals might
appear to be complicated when trying to
use them in mathematics everyone in
Europe had only ever known them it was
obvious to everyone back then that zip
plus Xavier equals LA obviously all
joking aside this had been the way that
things had been done for thousands of
years so why did they change and how
Arabic numerals call so because they
came to Europe through trade with the
Arabic world they actually originated in
India by the way were first introduced
to Europe in the 9th century and in fact
pope sylvester ii was heavily in favor
of they used but they never took off it
wasn't until the 13th century the tara
big numerals began to spread to
merchants some or perhaps much of this
was down to the work of Leonardo of Pisa
better known as Fibonacci who basically
wrote a mathematical textbook which
argued that Arabic numerals were
superior
Fibonacci's arguments for adopting were
convincing and many merchants in pisa
adopted the new system at least
temporarily since it was soon afterwards
banned there were two main reasons for
this which also white took so long for
Arabic numerals to be adopted in the
rest of Europe one the new system was
open to fraud with Roman numerals
merchants would use a flick with the
last iron a number to mark that it was
the last one something hard to tamper
with whereas anyone could turn a 3 into
an 8 and make it look like somebody owed
more money than they did and reason
number 2 because the system was imported
from the Islamic world it made Christian
lead his emergence uneasy who often at
the very least saw the use of it as
being unchristian and in the eyes of
church leaders had also promoted trade
with the Islamic world which was seen as
a no-no this setback took another two
centuries to overcome when our big
numeral started popping up all over
Europe Renaissance universities were
quick to start instruction in Arabic
numerals yet they took centuries to
spread because bankers and merchants
didn't attend university and so were
instructed in the better understood
Roman numerals and another reason was
because of cultural conservatism Roman
numerals had been used literally for
millennia and were good enough for the
Romans so why change anything
it was only when the Renaissance really
took off and old institutions were for
the first time question that the use of
Roman numerals work we read the new
leaders in Italy were students of the
Renaissance and many like the Medici
banking family brought Arabic numerals
with them for them it was the efficiency
in mathematics as an example would do 13
times 13 in Roman numerals two columns
one of the numbers being multiplied in
each add a new line half the number in
the left column and doubled the number
in the right you keep going until the
half number gets to one then cross out
any rows where the number in the left
column is even at the right column
together and there's your answer hence
why we got rid of them there after
leaving only monarchs in the occasional
calendar still using Roman numerals I
hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to all my patreon
supporters James vis annette marvin
castle a man of culture danny Meloni Jon
viscous Rob Waterhouse Moe Aaron the
white James Castaneda Gustav Swan Jordan
long ray
Marcus Ozma spinning three plates
cooling Castleman filled oink oink
Rashid Ali David Silverman easy Maggie
packs Kowski Spencer Lightfoot Winston
Cawood Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn
Anthony Beckett and Skye Chappell I'm
gonna get yelled at for calling them
Arabic numerals aren't I